do we believe him this time well this
time I think we do because it's been
pushed back push back push back but on
the last earnings call they didn't push
it back but they stuck to the date
saying it will be released in three to
four months time something else must
also said is that he's been test driving
this SUV himself he said it will be a
better SUV than the Model S will be as a
sedan and what's interesting he's told
us that more women are signing up to buy
this car SUVs simply appeal to women
whereas the Model S audience the
customers the majority of them are all
men essentially a software update is
coming out for the Model S it
potentially a month that'll have more
auto driving self driving features he
also says he's been personally testing
out those features himself specifically
saying I'm testing the latest version of
autopilot every week typically two or
three builds per week that I'm testing
on my own car but it is quite a tricky
thing and we have to make sure that the
testing is exhaustive before releasing
the software so this could be a move
towards the era of the self-driving car
their expectation at Tesla is there will
actually be someone in the car behind
the wheel to take over if something
happens but pretty interesting that musk
himself is personally testing out these
auto driving feature